we're here with Steve case one of the
top entrepreneurs in America one of the
top Venture Capitals in America and now
one of the top authors in America
congratulations Steve thank you you know
tell us tell us about your book rise of
the rest you know a decade traveling
around the country trying to find
entrepreneurs in different parts of the
country trying to support startup
communities like like here in the
Detroit we actually launched our first
rise rest bus tour eight years ago in
Detroit so it's great to be back with us
under 30 Summit and after spending the
decade traveling around these were
fascinating stories about companies and
also cities on the rise felt like I had
to write the book and came out last week
and was immediately on the best seller
chart so it's obviously resonating with
the people which is great to see well
congratulations again one of the great
stats in the book of course that 75
percent of the Venture Capital goes to
just three states right California
Massachusetts what's your advice now
having travel around and found all these
great entrepreneurs for somebody who's
not in one of those three states who
wants to raise money to start you know
to start that next Great American
Business well first of all stay where
you are don't feel like you have have to
go to Silicon Valley to raise money in
the last decade one of the most
encouraging statistics is 1400 new
Regional Venture firms have started up
there are seating these companies in
your area so you almost certainly have
local Capital figure out how to tap into
that if there's some strategic reason
you need to be someplace else you should
consider it but if you're leaving
because you feel like you have to leave
because that's where all the action is
that's where all the money is that is
starting to change over the next decade
I think it really will accelerate has
the pandemic helped or hurt this push
this Rises I hate to say it because it's
you know the pandemic was so tragic but
if you're looking for a silver lining in
a difficult you know period it's it has
led people to rethink kind of how they
work and how they live and where they
work and where they live and has led to
a dispersion of talent beginning of a
dispersion of capital so I think you
know 10 years from now we'll look back
and say that that pandemic actually was
the accelerant that really LED for the
the rise rest cities to rise a lot
faster and more companies to start and
scale in the in these other cities well
you know rise of the rest is more than
just Geographic you point on the book
less than 10 of venture capital goes to
you know women-based startups less than
one percent for black LED startups so
how do we change that well part of it is
going to these cities which are more
diverse and even this conference
reflects that it's more diverse in terms
of the entrepreneurs from other places
and also you know a more diverse mix of
backgrounds over 40 percent of the
companies we back now with our rise of
rest fund which is 200 companies and 100
cities are diverse Founders they're
female Founders or founders of color so
we're making a little bit of progress
but there's still a lot to be done on
that front front as well is there a
favorite you know as you've traveled the
country what's you know who's your most
unusual entrepreneur that you guys have
found and gotten behind well I ducked
that question because when you back 200
entrepreneurs it's kind of being asked
like who's your favorite child who's
your favorite child of course
I would say that there's some things in
my heart about Detroit which is why we
started our first tour here eight years
ago and why I come back every year or so
and it's and it's great to have the this
Forbes event here there's something
about the Detroit story that really
resonates partly as you you know the
backstory that 100 years ago Detroit
sort of was Silicon Valley well it was
you know when Silicon Valley was going
through the assembly line you know that
the automobile was the hot technology of
the day and then lost its way the year
before we rolled in on our rise of rest
bus the city of Detroit went bankrupt uh
but it's over the last decade really
been fighting its way back and we backed
a number of companies here Shinola
stockx you know a handful of others that
really are part of this Rebirth of of
Detroit and that story is now happening
all over the country but people don't
know it that's why that's why I wrote
the book I think it will anybody reading
the book will be inspired by the
entrepreneurs intrigued by how many
cities are rising and be a little more
hopeful about the future of our country
well again spending time with you is
hopeful I know we got to go on stage but
thank you first of all we're in Detroit
because of this guy Steve Casey made the
introduction to Dan Gilbert and now
you've got we've put over 10 000 people
10 000 entrepreneurs through Detroit so
good luck number you know it's rising up
it's amazing thank you not just having
conferences in in the usual places like
you know New York and California but
look looking for different parts of the
country to really shine a spotlight on
them sure most of the people came to
Detroit hadn't been there before some
they probably fell in love with the city
and are going to start their companies
here that's what we want to have all
over the country well you're on your way
we appreciate everything you've done for
the whole Glo you know National
ecosystem thank you Randall thank you
[Music]